siamo solo il menù è già sento quel
profumo di sterco guardate di ragazzi di
questo nuovo video io sono parte di
samsung è di spaghetti 2.0 è uscito
freddi spaghetti 2.0 non chiedetemi il
motivo perché già nel primo fra gli
spaghetti non si capiva una sega però
facciamo i due ha detto va bene facciamo
il 2 vediamo cosa succede imprendi
spaghetti e narrato
ecco a cosa uscirà fuori giusto ok
freddi avete assunto proprio lui e la ci
siamo di nuovo ragazzi speravo di non
tornare mai più in questo punto ma
evidentemente siamo fatti per giocarlo a
fra il disponente hanno assunto freddi
in questo in questo posto dove si fanno
lì non so cosa si fa superata però sono
un dipendente quindi comportiamoci bene
e arriviamo sul posto di lavoro in
orario prima cosa le dico io lavoro devo
mettere a posto i server va bene non
vedo come io possa fare visto che sono
skillato con le mie mani fatate in
qualche modo stanno ci sono dei surfers
line il server offline frenetici e bravo
bravo non è difficile lavoro del tecnico
è comunque quello che io ho imparato in
cinque anni di informatica sul posto
celine cerco e questo è quello che so
fare io quindi non è tanto distante
dalla realtà però c'è freddi che con
casinò ed è saltato il server fa niente
tanto nei rami non ho perso ad andare
così segnata giocare a ping bonomi
lipidi socio non puoi joe che sei uno
spaghetto come pozzi come ma non ci
arrivo neanche sprecato cosa vuol dire
sprecato solo spaghetto tutto sto casino
sto anche rischiando di cadere dal
tavolo mamma mia mamma mia che rischio
punto pregi sembra un po strano
la sua pausa pranzo andato a fare una
nuotata beh vedo che comunque due ha più
senso dell'uro come gioco ragazzi ormai
non sono anche più capendo cosa stoffa
sprecato a qua devo fare parkour tra una
roba e l'altra va bene che poi non sa se
ci pensate non ha un senso perché fino
adesso abbiamo camminato per terra però
sprecato perché sprechiamo non si spreca
il cibo freddi e tu lo sei
mio dio ma perché salto fatto perfetto
perfetto bellissimo bellissimo
mamma mia che pro gamer no sono ancora
vivo non so come sempre beh io che devo
parlare quando non devo sempre questo
mamma mia che ansia equa e quando volevo
giocarmela bene e ragga teoricamente ci
dovrebbe arrivare con un mega salto
proprio lui da un divano all'altro vedi
che comunque non mi a sport preferito è
da sempre in giro ma cosa me ne frega
ma perché ma perché quando si intermezzi
non hanno senso
mi scusi lei è la receptionist devo
chiede fare qualcosa non lo farei di
questi sono momenti chiave di che prima
non ho toccato per terra adesso sì certo
gioco come la spiega qualcuno mi spiega
vi prego non capiscono
continuo a non capire se sembra the
office
avete presente la serie a deve aiutarli
a mettersi insieme
bye bye lo spingono stingo vai vai vai
guarda che il supporto morale ti do da
amico vai fallere dee fai vedere che sei
un uomo gentile che ci tiene e vai c'e
ray eyes of a righe non si innamora di
mai ragazzi come fatto con il problema
non solo
e quindi mi sembra un'esagerazione
tra l'altro io gioco con e vogliamo
sempre nel mezzo a dei di la cambia
cambia e va capito c'è solo e solo in
mezzo il portiere almeno tirava lato io
non ci credo porca vacca sono stupido
che difesa orribile bravo io non ai
rulli cioè come cacchio gioco gioco a
caso mib va bene ok rally madonna che
tiro questo no per questo la cr7 non lo
farà neanche shenzhen importa questo
ragazzi incredibile mi dispiace quando
giocano a biliardo aiuto giocare
abbigliato con il collare
ma dove sono sì c'è un problema non ha
renderizzato freddi c'è un problema
regia il gioco ci ha dei problemi di suo
credo che ce l'abbia più del solito
norma renderizza perché non sul tavolo
ok ora niente non è che non aveva
indirizzato kever datato sto andando da
un'altra parte io conosca c'entra
neanche niente turn anche giocando a
biliardo cioè il 2 veramente non ha
senso riprendi spaghetti in orari non ha
niente nella trama nonché una trama che
dove c'è uno spaghetto abbiamo senso
però va bè ragazzi sta cosa sta
diventando un attimino poco gestibile
visto che comunque ho fatto 60 due
livelli uno me che ha meno senso
dell'altro
e ancora non ho capito dove stiamo
andando a parare con la trama non cadrà
che ci sia una trama incredibile in un
gioco facciamo spaghetto che si muove
però vabbè bello l'ufficio lo conosco a
memoria
c'è da dire c'è di buono questo ma non
ho capito dove stiamo andando a finire
ci stiamo continuando senza un senso ei
x mas che poi cos'è
non mi sento proprio il king soprattutto
dopo questo tiro gioco sopra va bene vai
dritto nora gamba impossibile è come
giocare a dark souls cena lei non si può
fare non ci riesce stephen curry proprio
lui
mamma mia ci ho messo sei ore cosa me ne
frega cosa me ne frega della vostra
storia d'amore cosa me ne frega solo uno
spaghetto come le deve fregare niente
jack di qualcosa e non dice niente però
in tutto questo i numero fare niente
domandate un punto all'altro ragazzi sto
gioco non ha senso non ha veramente quel
senso di esistere
spiegatemi ma cosa diavolo rovesciato il
peperoncino
questo perché quello non mi sembrava
tutto meno che peperoncino tutto meno
che peperoncino era quello ma ti pongo
di nuovo facciamo il round 2 zio rock
due ragazzi fan cronache di lui in
ufficio comunque un'ottima serie tv
mamma mia ma toner che sono un giocatore
incredibile
basta è finita tranne l'ultimo colpo che
sicuramente mancherò loro mancato
ragazzi sta iniziando a farmi fare
livelli di prima quindi non so quanto
questa roba possa andare avanti
sinceramente
credo che possiamo concludere qua dopo
aver giocato a questa perla videoludica
little light mestre comunque mi sembra
cioè credo che la trama sia più o meno
quella questo gioco qualunque è stato
veramente splendido sono contento di
averlo portato sul mio canale perché non
vedo il perchè io non debba portare
giochi del genere però che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi e freddi vi salutiamo e
saliamo le scale nel mentre che è chiuso
il video molta ma c'è poi vi lamentate
che comunque io porto contenuti non di
valore cioè ragazzi dovete solo stare
zitti
non so come possiate parlare male dei
miei video come cioè non vedo non ne
vedo il motivo anche per il fatto che
sono andato più indietro che avanti in
questo scalinata che quello è un altro
discorso
signori spera vini sia piaciuto al sodo
metto vi piace soprattutto per freddy
noi riusciremo a salire le scale magari
nel prossimo video dove dedicheremo
tutto il tempo a questo livello visto
che non è facile non lo è riuscito ad
aspettare che ha prima di chiudere il
video perfetto fantastico
[Musica]